the stunningly animated riot and the
last dragon
introduces disney's first southeast
asian princess
the fantasy world of kumandra and its
mystical water dragons
curiously hidden in the movie are many
references easter eggs and similarities
to disney's previous animated hit frozen
2.
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing all the secret
connections details and parallels
between
raya sisu and disney's ice queen elsa
plus stick around to the end of the
video to find out about the original
much darker ending disney had planned
for the last dragon
spoilers ahead of course so take care
many disney fans have noticed an
interesting visual and somewhat uncanny
similarity between sisu and elsa
in particular sisu's face which has
extra large and expressive eyes
it's interesting because the final
version of sisu in the movie has some
notable differences from the original
concept art of the dragon which had much
smaller eyes and sharper teeth and fangs
sisu is also predominantly blue in the
final movie with only touches of purple
whereas she had a lot more purple in the
initial design
as well as some white colors this
dominant blue coloring on sisu makes the
magical dragon more reminiscent of elsa
whose signature colour has often been
blue as well
and many fans are so convinced about the
visual similarities of the two
that they jokingly suggest elsa got
bored of being the fifth spirit after a
few years and decided to become a dragon
of course both sisu and elsa's abilities
are water-based so naturally the colour
blue fits them both well
too and i'll be talking more about the
water dragons in the film
shortly it's interesting how key moments
in both rya and the last dragon and
frozen two
occur when the main protagonists
encounter the remains of a shipwreck
raya comes across the wreckage of a boat
after her search for the river's end
where legend says that sisu is sleeping
inside the ship as raya summons sisu the
water
in the stream reverses direction large
drops float into the air and combine to
reform as the legendary water dragon
this feels reminiscent of frozen two
where elsa used her magic to pull water
that was embedded in the hull of the
wrecked ship to create an
ice sculpture that held the memories of
the last moments of her parents
and raya's comment when she sees a ship
for the first time
six years of searching and we end up at
a literal
shipwreck feels like a wink to frozen
fans about their six-year wait between
the first and second movie for the
reveal of the truth about what had
really happened to elsewhere and anna's
parents king agnar and queen oduna
in riot and the last dragon we learned
that 500 years ago the world
came under attack from the droon
amorphous and destructive spirits who
turned both people and dragons into
stone
four of the only five surviving dragons
decided to combine their powers and
magic
into a dragon gem which they entrusted
to their sibling sisu the fifth dragon
who then used the power of the gem to
defeat the plague of droon
similarly in frozen two it's the fifth
spirit elsa who together with honor
breaks the curse on the enchanted forest
and saves arendelle from destruction
in both movies there are five magical
elements
in raya each of the five dragons has a
distinct power
this is my little sister ambas magic i
got the glow
and that's prani she's a shape-shifter
fog that was my brother jagan's magic
and pangu he's our big brother he brings
the reign
i'm a really strong swimmer
and in frozen two there are five spirits
gale the wind element bruni the fire
spirit the earth giants the knock water
spirit
and elsa the fifth spirit who together
with her sister honor forms a bridge
connecting nature with humanity
the importance of five elements in riot
and the last dragon is also emphasized
in the very opening shot of the movie
with this picture of a stone structure
with five curved supports holding up the
top
one of these is broken signaling either
how the world is broken or perhaps
pointing to the missing fifth dragon
sisu who raya is searching for
there's also five stone balls with the
four smaller ones on the outside
representing the four dragons who gave
their powers to create the dragon gem
which is represented by the large ball
in the center
and there are of course five kingdoms in
kumandra and at the end of the story one
person from each of the five kingdoms
come together to save their world
now in many traditions numbers also have
a symbolic
quality with the number five often
symbolizing
balance mankind health and love even
bearing this in mind though it's still
intriguing that disney has chosen to
feature this particular symbolism in
both of their most recent animated
features
in both movies too our protagonists end
up sacrificing themselves or temporarily
dying as they
reach the end of their quest for raya
she's the first in her group to give her
piece of the dragon gem to namari and
trust in her
assisi wanted her to without the gem's
protection the droon turn
rya to stone similar to how elsa froze
entirely when she dove too deep into
atta harlan's memories
and in the first frozen movie anna too
turned to ice when she sacrificed
herself to save elsa from the evil huns
nobody stays dead and rya comes back to
life after
namari puts the dragon gem back together
which unleashes the power of the dragons
on the drone
while in frozen two elsa is unfrozen
when anna lifts the curse on the
enchanted forest by destroying the
arendellian dam
another interesting similarity between
both films is the importance of water to
the final resolution
in roya and the last dragon the rain
which falls liberates everyone from
their stony fate
whereas in frozen two when the dam
breaks the resulting tsunami almost
destroys arendelle as it flows down the
fjord towards the kingdom
until elsa arrives in the nick of time
to stop it
water is of course a hugely important
motif in raya and the last dragon
as it's the only element other than the
dragon gem itself which can ward off the
drone
they're repelled by water and tellingly
raya is even called dewdrop by her
father benja
sisu is also a water dragon and her
design as well as her siblings was
inspired by the southeast asian naga
mythical divine or semi-divine beings
the naga are often more serpentine in
appearance than the european style of
dragon usually depicted in disney movies
and they're sometimes associated with
the mekong river which was actually the
inspiration for the dragon-shaped river
that runs through and connects all of
kumandra's five kingdoms
this is water it's sort of my thing but
sisu also has a curious parallel with
frozen two's elemental water spirit the
noc
though that is of course based on
scandinavian mythology
in the original folklore the knock has
the ability to shapeshift and turn into
a man or woman much like sisu does in
riot and the last dragon
i just shape changed into people dragons
can do that
look at my my people arms and my people
face look how close my butt is to my
head
while the nagger that sisu is based on
are also sometimes portrayed as half
human half serpent
and as always the frozen fandom has been
quick to catch on to these similarities
swapping out an image of the knock for
sisu in this picture of elsa after she
stops the flood
another thematic similarity between raya
and the last dragon and frozen 2
is how human discord and treachery
triggers a kind of natural or mystical
antagonist which is something
disney has explored in other recent
films like moana in contrast to more
conventional animated villains such as
maleficent and cruella deville
when the maori portrays ryan's trust to
try and steal the dragon gem for the
fang people it causes all of kumandra's
kingdoms to fight each other over the
stone and when they end up breaking the
gem it awakens the droon who now pose an
existential threat to all of kumandra
likewise in frozen 2
it was king runard's betrayal of an
attack on the north uldra which angered
the spirits who then cursed the
enchanted forest
trapping everyone inside and preventing
anyone from entering or leaving
an especially interesting detail about
both movies is that at one time disney
originally had much darker endings
planned for both of them
in raya and the last dragon sisu dies
when namari betrays raya again and the
subsequent confrontation goes wrong
in an interview with polygon the
filmmakers explained that sisu
dying was always part of the original
plan so that raya would learn the dragon
wasn't somebody who would magically
rescue commander from the drone and that
instead she and the others would have to
learn to trust one another in order to
defeat them
just like sisu and the other dragons had
done 500 years before
in the final film sisu is resurrected
later on together with all her dragon
siblings
however there was a version of the movie
where sisi remained dead after the rain
fell
and no other dragons were resurrected
either meaning sisu was
literally the last dragon as one of the
film's producers pointed out if humans
are the solution
why are we bringing the magical mystical
creatures back
in the end though the filmmakers felt
they wanted to go with a happy
ending and a big disney moment that
makes your heart sing
and so sisu and the dragons came back
now
depending on your viewpoint the original
ending might have been more striking
because it would have solidified the
sacrifice the dragons made for kumandra
and made the consequences of human
discord and strife more long-lasting
likewise frozen too almost had a much
darker ending where arendelle castle was
destroyed by the flood from the broken
dam
making the consequences of king runard's
betrayal of the northuldra more
impactful
the original scene of the aftermath also
shows how honour planned to use the
destruction as an opportunity for
renewal in the kingdom
we'll rebuild the castle new no secrets
no deceit new rules even and if you want
to learn more about frozen two's other
deleted scenes there's a card here and a
link in the video description
another notable detail is the diamond
pattern on the walls of the heartland
palace
which reminds me of the diamonds that
suddenly appeared over arendelle during
into the unknown
this could be a frozen two easter egg or
it could likely be a reference to the
diamond motifs you can see on
fang jewellery such as those on chief
verana's earring and neck ring
given we see these diamond patterns just
as raya is confiding in namari and is
about to take her to see the dragon gem
it might be a clue to the imminent fang
betrayal
so did you spot any other interesting
easter eggs or details in the movie
comment with your thoughts and theories
below and if you enjoyed this don't
forget to leave a thumbs up it's really
appreciated
you can also tap left for those frozen
two deleted scenes and alternate ending
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers